welcome back to the show Benjamin Dixon
filling in for David Pakman this next
story really rubs me in the wrong way
and I'm sure once you hear it it would
do the same to you
there is a new way of funding education
higher education and I'm not entirely
sure how new it is because I do recall
being offered an income sharing
agreement to fund my PhD program when I
started it
haven't finished but I started it but I
digress what it does basically is
instead of you getting a loan from the
government are backed by the government
and paying back quasi government
agencies like Sallie Mae over time
investors from Wall Street can look at
you as an individual and determine how
much your future self is worth and say
we'll pay for your education if you give
us a percentage of your income until
this is paid off until your debt to us
is paid off it's called an income
sharing agreement there's an article in
Bloomberg comm that tells a story of a
young lady who went to Purdue University
and she got one of these is a s and this
is what the article said quote to fund
part of the cost of her degree in
strategy and organizational management
she sidestepped the common source of
money a student loan instead she agreed
to hand over part of her future earnings
through a new kind of financial
instrument called an income sharing
agreement or an is a in a sense finance
seers are transforming student debtors
into stock investments which with much
of the same risk and ideally return I
mean this is this is terrible this this
it's terrible on so many levels
it's terrible on level one because why
in the hell would students in the United
States and the richest country in this
on the face of this planet have to sell
off their future value to private
investors in order to pay for their
education when nations like Germany give
free higher education to all their
citizens and a highly reduced education
to foreigners
but here in the United States in order
to find new ways of funding our
education we're having to turn Wall
Street basically commodifying our
humanity in exchange for an education to
benefit an education that's inevitably
going to be beneficial to this broader
society so in a sense we are giving we
not in a sense every person who goes to
get a higher education we are
contributing to the society therefore it
should be something that the government
pays for but that's not what the story's
about this is about America's
irresponsibility america's refusal to
take care of the very people who are
going to take care of it and because of
that gross negligence we're now turning
to Wall Street and not just to get a
loan but for people to sell off their
values selling yourself for an education
selling off their future value in
exchange for education today that's
number one number two it this story
wrote is so so disturbing because it
shows you how how just thirsty it's the
best vernacular I could think of right
now that doesn't involve profanity how
greedy and opportunistic Wall Street is
the fact that there's they're vultures
they're sitting there waiting for an
opportunity to make another dime and
they look and they see people say that
individual they probably are going to be
worth about $60,000 a year so if I can
get about $200 a month out of them I
could clear a profit stack them up give
me about a thousand of those in one
portfolio and and I've diversified
myself and I've got a new stream of
revenue this is this is literally out
there looking at human potential they're
looking at the future of individuals at
children they're looking at children
going into college and saying when you
grow up I'm going to be able to milk
money off of you directly not enough
that I make money off of you on
everything that you buy it's not enough
that I make money off of you off of
everything that you eat it's not enough
that I can make money off of the roads
that you travel on especially if Donald
Trump gets this
infrastructure bill that where they're
going to be privatizing so many roads
it's not enough that I make all the
money I want to make off of you off of
your living I want to make money off of
your value your intrinsic value or at
least what your education says your
value is that is so opportunistic that
is so vulture istic I don't know if
that's where it I just made it up if
it's not it just shows you the depravity
of the profit driven motive and how it
will seek out every opportunity to
exploit humanity anyway let me get off
of my my my stoop here's what elizabeth
warren had to say about it on twitter
she said quote it's disturbing that at
USA us and gov is exploring income share
agreements student debt contracts that
allow private investors to exploit
students especially students of color as
badly as some of the most predatory and
costly private student loans it's it's
it's not bad enough that Sallie Mae is
hunting every probably ninety percent of
David's audience in my audience they're
hunting us haunting and haunting us
every single day
it's bad enough now our children are
going to be able to sell off their
future value or the value that's
associated with the degree that they get
in exchange for the education when
education should be free in this country
in the first place higher education it
should be free in this country in the
first place but here's what I just want
to just put a fine point on this here's
what one investor said about the
opportunity he said this in Bloomberg he
said quote I have vision a whole new
equity market for higher education in
the next five years where today's where
today there's only debt says Chuck
draftin who runs a hedge fund the hedge
fund flow point Capital Partners LP
which has invested in ISAs including
Purdue's I including Purdue is a experts
say that they have fielded calls from
some of the world's largest investment
managers and are considering investing
in the contracts they to them this is
progress
to them this is the future that they
won't they see they see nothing wrong
with individuals
having to turn over a portion of their
income now I mean is it is it analogous
to what the government already does with
student loan in a way it is right
because you get a loan you have to pay
it back but but what it does like it
terms it it incentivizes Wall Street's
worst behaviors whereas it's pretty bad
the interest rate that Sallie Mae is now
hitting people across Nelnet is a was an
l net that's a billion dollar company
now one of these one of these student
loan companies is a billion dollar
industry company by themselves now
they're constrained however by
regulations we shouldn't have that in
the first place no one should have to
pay for a higher education because of
the benefit that it turns and gives to
the society it is not as though we're
getting higher education just to sit and
and and to do nothing
people get higher education so that they
can be that so that they can contribute
to society and so because every person
who takes four years of their life in
order to educate themselves they're
doing so predominantly a majority to
give back to society in some form of
fashion it's a net benefit for this
civilization so it is an investment that
the government should be making so no
there should not be government backed
student loans however those government
batch student loans are constrained by
regulation this is a whole new it's a
whole new way of thinking about it in
which it turns humans students children
into commodities for which Wall Street
has an opportunity to make a profit and
where goes and so goes every other
financial issue in this country that
means there's an opportunity to have
this entire industry operate with
impunity with no regulation simply
because that's what Republicans go for
in every case in every instance so this
presents an opportunity for an higher
level of exploitation I personally want
to get rid of the first one student
loans backed by the government education
should be free but we certainly can get
a lot worse than what we currently have
and these income sharing agreements are
absolutely an example of how what's bad
can get a whole lot worse